but don't you think it's interesting  that they label like men can't criticize  modern women because they'll be labeled  misogynists women can't criticize modern  women because they'll be labeled to pick  me so nobody can criticize these women  isn't that convenient yeah and then  they'll go to the personal attacks like  well why aren't you why are you single  and I'm like that's what I'm saying true  or is it not true I'll be like Rebecca  seven abortions is a lot I don't know  what you're doing I mean a girl had  seven her name's not actually Rebecca  seven abortions wow seven and I'm like  that's a lot that is madness and it's  like is that true or is it untrue or  should we encourage it to get to ten  should we encourage it to get to ten  [Music]